[Applaudissements]
ça marche
oui il me regardait quand même et bien
un bonjour à tous merci d'être si
nombreux
je suis très très heureuse de vous
retrouver tous
cet après midi
allez je vais vous la voyez je suis ici
avec avec émotion mais aussi d'ailleurs
avec espoir et confiance en l'avenir
je suis ici avec émotion et espoir parce
que je suis chez toi mon cher laurent au
siège de ta belle région et c'est vrai
qu'à lyon aussi c'est fait tant et tant
d'histoires pour notre pays
alors oui c'est formidable d'être à lyon
et puis oui c'est les lyonnais là ils
sont pas très nombreux jeux impression
et puis je voudrais dire que je suis à
la fois émue et heureuse que nous nous
réunissions 1 16 mars 16 mars est très
symbolique 16 mars
ça a été la victoire aux législatives
après cinq ans de mitterrand et je pense
que c'est un beau symbole
accessoirement c'était aussi ma première
élection sur un mandat national et je
m'en souviens et c'est aussi une des
raisons de mon émotion
alors aujourd'hui je dirais que lyon ce
16 mars
ça va être le début ça va être la
première marche d'une grande reconquête
et j'en suis persuadé avec vous tous
avec vous les élus avec vous les cadres
du mouvement avec vous les militants
nous allons reconquérir la france pour
nos idées nous allons le faire pour
notre avenir nous allons le faire pour
notre pays
et de ce point de vue et de ce point de
vue les européennes c'est un la première
marche et elle n'est pas anecdotique
elle n'est pas anecdotique parce que
c'est vrai qu'entre janvier
nous avons besoin de l'europe nous avons
besoin de l'europe dans un monde qui est
un monde compliqué dans un monde qui est
un monde incertain dans un monde mon
cher hervé qui est un monde dangereux
bien plus dangereux que quand toi et moi
nous étions au ministère de la défense
aujourd'hui entre ce qui se passe au
moyen-orient
les tensions qui existent entre l'arabie
saoudite et l'iran ce qui se passe en
extrême orient ce qui se passe en
afrique
nous sommes dans un monde dangereux est
un monde dangereux qui a des
répercussions y compris sur notre propre
sol européen mon cher joseph
nous voyons bien à travers des attentats
à travers des tensions nous sommes aussi
dans un monde qui est un monde anxiogène
et c'est vrai c'est vrai que les
français comme tous les européens
d'ailleurs s'angoisse parce qu'ils ont
le sentiment d'avoir plus de repères de
n'avoir plus de valeur d'une sorte de
banalisation de la culture qui nous a
fait ce que nous sommes
alors c'est vrai que nous avons besoin
de redonner du sens et de l'efficacité
du pragmatisme et du concret à l'europe
l'europe
nous en avons besoin pour notre sécurité
l'europe nous en avons besoin pour notre
prospérité
l'europe nous en avons besoin pour la
valorisation de nos atouts et moi je
voudrais vous dire aujourd'hui
vous qui êtes parfois pessimiste
vous qui êtes au contact avec des
citoyens qui ont peur de l'avenir
il faut leur dire que tout n'est pas
négatif est que des atouts face aux
enjeux du monde des 50 prochaines années
nous en avons et nous les développons
d'autant mieux que nous serons au sein
d'une europe qui aura envie de partager
les mêmes actions et les mêmes valeurs
oui l'europe nous en avons besoin pour
notre sécurité nous avons hervé tu le
sais bien probablement l'une des trois
ou mais deux ou trois meilleures armées
au monde
pour autant si nous voulons rester à la
pointe du progrès nous avons aussi
besoin des crédits européens pour nous
permettre de toujours nous adapter et
nous avons besoin d'agir ensemble parce
qu'il va y avoir de plus en plus de
conflits et que nous ne serons pas en
rivalité avec le temps mais que nous ne
serons pas assez de deux organisations
pour répondre aux besoins qui vont être
ceux du monde à venir
alors je suis complètement d'accord avec
toi sur l'idée qu' une armée européenne
c'est une connerie 80 ans ça fait du
bien de se lâcher un peu
je pense que c'est une véritable amri
parce que ça n'a pas de sens est-ce
qu'on va accepter que ce soit qu'un un
bal tu où que ce soit que nos amis
belges qui décide d'envoyer les hommes
et les femmes de nos armées risquer de
se faire tuer à l'autre bout du monde
ça n'a pas de sens mais en revanche
mutualiser ce que nous pouvons avoir
cela a du sens de la même façon dans un
monde qui va être de plus en plus
nombreux nous avons l'atout d'être l'un
des premiers producteurs exportateurs
agroalimentaire mais à nous seuls nous
ne perdrons jamais pour obtenir la
nécessaire réciprocité pour obtenir le
respect des mêmes normes de production
des autres pays que d'une autre nous
avons besoin de l'europe pour renforcer
notre agriculture ici à lyon où il ya
les laboratoires mérieux
nous pouvons dire que nous avons les
meilleurs centres de recherche du monde
et nous avons probablement la meilleure
politique industrielle de santé du monde
mais il est évident que nous avons
besoin là aussi que l'europe soutiennent
d'autres éthique et soutiennent nos
actions en matière de santé de la même
façon en ce qui concerne tout le domaine
du spatial où tout le domaine de
l'aéronautique que ferions nous sans
airbus cet airbus est d'origine
française
mais nous avons eu besoin nous avons
encore besoin de l'europe pour cela et
je pourrais multiplier les exemples
oui je veux vous le dire et il faut que
vous le disiez autour de vous pour les
défis des 50 prochaines années nous
avons nous en france tous les atouts
nécessaires pour devenir des grands du
monde à condition effectivement d'avoir
le run et européens
alors oui nous avons besoin d'une europe
qui souhaitent europe concret pas une
europe de discours mais une réelle
europe de projets c'est ce que nous
voulons faire c'est ce qui est dans
votre programme et je m'en réjouis
la france ne se perd pas dans une europe
de projets elle y développe au contraire
ces potentiels mais il est évident que
ce n'est pas n'importe quelle europe
il faut que ce soit une europe concrète
et une europe de projets je vous dire
lorsque vous faites une recherche sur
internet
ou est-ce que vous allez vous êtes sur
google lorsque vous regardez une série
vous utilisez bête flix lorsque vous
achetez vous utilisez amazon lorsque
vous cherchez un emploi vous consultez
indeed ou ventures et tout ça ça vous
choque pas aucun de ces grands ensembles
net européen
et bien si nous ne voulons pas être
complètement dépassés ce que doit faire
l'europe c'est ça c'est nous permettre
de créer des grands et nous devons agir
en ce sens parce que ce n'est pas
naturel et au contraire il ya quelques
jours
combien l'europe vient de prendre une
décision contraire ça n'est pas possible
nous avons tous mais encore faut-il
qu'on nous laisse faire notre création
alors il nous faut une europe de projets
il nous faut aussi une europe humaine
c'est-à-dire une europe
jean françois xavier je pense que vous
commencez à le comprendre
une europe qui écoutent une europe qui
soit faite
pour les citoyens pour améliorer leur
vie au quotidien pour améliorer leurs
conditions de vie pour améliorer leur
pouvoir d'achat pour améliorer leur
sentiment de sécurité
une europe qui soit faite aussi par les
citoyens parce que ils ne doivent pas
croire il ne doit pas penser que
l'europe c'est quelque chose qui se fait
hors d'eux et qui se fait sans eux
alors oui oui je crois qu'il est
indispensable que nous redonnions une
envie d'europe à l'ensemble des français
lorsque je suis venu te voir mon cher
leur au mois de juillet
je t'ai dit il faut que cette liste que
tu vas faire elle ressemble aux français
les français ils ont envie de
renouvellement et ils ont envie en même
temps d'efficacité et pour créer il faut
donc que tu es à la fois des gens
d'expérience mais que tu es aussi un
vaste renouvellement et je t'ai dit je
te laisserai ma place je ne me
représenterai pas pour que tu puisses
pas être une personne de plus qu'ils
soient des jeunes qui est envie d'y
aller et qu'ils sachent donner envie aux
français
alors laurent ne se dit pas simplement à
françois-xavier parce qu'il a le temps
mais pour toi c'est quand même pas
première campagne nationale
tu dois redonner aux français l'envi de
cette europe cette europe que nous avons
défini ensemble cette europe que vous
postez françois-xavier avec toute
l'équipe que je salue chaleureusement
laurent il faut aussi que tu donnes
france l envie de faire campagne
vous avez tous envie de faire campagne
je le sais eh bien ils volent et
d'antoine avec vous il faut entraîner
tout le monde c'est comme ça que nous
gagnerons d'une campagne elle se gagne
voià prévoit chaque personne que vous
amènerez avec vous vous permettra de
gagner vous permettra de faire prévaloir
notre vision de l'europe nous permettra
de montrer à toute l'europe que la
france est prête à s'engager pour son
futur
c'est ça votre domaine et c'est ça ta
responsabilité et puylaurens c'est vrai
que c'est la première étape est donc ce
qu'il faut aussi c'est que tu donnes
envie aux français de s'engager en
politique tu sais moi je prends toi je
t'ai toujours défendu et je te défendre
et je soutiendrai de toutes les ford
cette liste et je soutiendrai tout ce
que tu feras et qui ira dans le sens de
la grandeur de notre pays le rang
laurent chacun porte en soi un peu de
l'histoire des autres de ceux qui ont
pété avant lui
moi je sais que je retrouve en toi
beaucoup de jacques chirac
sa générosité à l'égard de la vie son
amour de nos territoires
sa volonté de dépassement malgré les
difficultés et tu en a eu et tu en auras
encore ne te fais pas d'illusions sa
vision des grands enjeux du monde ça tu
le portes en toi et je m'en réjouis
c'est ça aussi qui fait la chair de la
politique la politique elle n'est jamais
d incarner vous ne seriez pas là vous
n'auriez pas laisser vos familles
vous n'auriez pas laissé toutes vos
activités si vous ne croyez pas en soi
hausse là oui il ya de jacques chirac en
toi et ya aussi nicolas sarkozy il ya de
nicolas sarkozy par ton énergie il y a
de nicolas sarkozy dans ton envie de
convaincre il y a de nicolas sarkozy
dans sa capacité d'entraînement il y a
de nicolas sarkozy dans sa volonté de
promouvoir les jeunes
alors oui tu as tout pour réussir à
condition que les petits cochons ne le
mangent pas et des petits cochons il y
en a beaucoup
autrefois c'était des éléphants
maintenant c'est des petits cochons
chacun à son niveau
eh bien mon cher le rond avec toi avec
toute cette liste dynamique et
sympathique
nous devons ensemble entamé la marche
vers les futures victoires car ces
victoires c'est ensemble que nous les
construire on nous les construire ont
pour nos concitoyens nous les construire
ont pour notre parti et surtout nous les
construire ont pour l'europe et pour la
france
[Applaudissements]